more things you didn't know about breath
of the wild you know what you came for
if you enjoy this series let us know
with a like we love showing off what's
new and possible in this endless game
alright here we go after completing the
great plateau you should really never be
afraid of mud pits just know how hard
you hit the mud is what causes you to
immediately drown
meaning softly landing or walking into
mud allows you to stay afloat
by using a cryonis block beneath your
feet then paragliding back onto the mud
you can cross any pit with absolutely no
problem
the toon link amiibo can be used to
propagate live fish into strange places
that you've never seen fish swimming
before
such as the great fairy fountain now
you've got your own aquarium where you
can feed your fish
on the same note as a previous two
tricks did you know that fish can fully
survive and
swim in mud and for a short time even in
freezing water and lava
well until they freeze or burn up
most players just whistle to their horse
to command them to return but there's
another
special way to travel with your
companion but it requires a bit of
timing
by standing in front of it whistling
then jogging during the middle of the
whistle
it will continue to follow right behind
you
that's a good horsey did you know that
the generic open books around hyrule are
just one big joke
when translated from hylian each book
says april 1st
today was a dry hot and sunny day i went
to school
this diary is very important document
april 2nd
yesterday was fool's day everything that
i wrote was false
that is all see you tomorrow
kilton's shop name is called fang and
bone but its official name
might be written in hylian right on its
sharp roof savage swaps
breath of the wild has a lot of dialogue
and scripts and is inevitable at some
point that there would be some typos
somewhere
such as a grammatical error for the
under the red moon quest
another grammatical error on the desert
bow trousers description
and a typo at the rideau village's
slippery falcon which in hylian
translates to
shop pigeon there's one
object in the game that can stasis
launch in multiple directions at once
flying octorock forts in master mode
even when disconnected
are all able to be stasis at once and
each platform can be launched in
separate directions this can set up some
neat looking situations
it makes me wish we had multi-stasis
from the beginning
when moblins block korok leafs gusts
they can also block
many other non-elemental attacks with
just their arms
it just doesn't look like it should but
i guess their arms are pretty buff
pretty much everyone in hyrule is not a
huge fan of you causing trouble
including carrying a bomb around or
pointing a weapon at them
understandable but what's funny is if
you're a night owl and you talk to
someone with the wake
option they're still too sleepy to know
what's going on
even if you have a flaming arrow shoved
in their face the new campfire glitch
has become quickly popular in being able
to steal the master sword
but it also has other uses as well such
as being able to save
during the yiga hideout mission being
able to warp directly out of hyrule
castle without going to the front gate
first
[Music]
and warp out of sandstorms when yoshiga
slate has no signal
players have been finding out that shiga
towers have a hidden chica design
all along right under our noses but not
only that they're also designed into the
side pillars as well
and that's not the only secret the side
platforms hold
did you know that while you're on any
side platform you acquire sniper like
zoom while aiming a weapon or a bow
it's actually the same exact sniper
property you normally get from golden
bows
this allows you to get the jump on a
distant enemy or get a much more
extensive lay of the land
if you know how to win bomb i've got an
easy trick for you if you want to launch
directly up but you don't have good
angles around you to jump from
save from where you want to launch from
then do a normal wind bomb in any
direction
as soon as you get hit watch a memory
then load the save
you'll rock it skyward when you load
back in
all shop items secretly cost 9999 mon
have 100 attack and have an extra bar of
stamina until their actual material id
shows up
damn that's some strong milk camouflaged
lizalfos have really weird interactions
when you're disguised they'll typically
ignore you
unless they witness you murderize their
friend in which they'll give you a death
stare
if you approach them then they'll attack
on sight makes sense but you can then
sneak strike them after their attack
and it only does normal damage then they
just turn around and forget everything
that just happened
you alright buddy horses give absolutely
no shits about lionel's explosions
like at all
the master cycle needs refueling to keep
running and pretty much everything is
just
thrown in the fuel tank except fairies
they have a special animation blessing
the fuel tank before flying away
it looks even cooler with multiple
fairies the master cycle also has the
ability to teleport fire when redeployed
by firing a fire arrow at the master
cycle then redeploying it
it will carry the fire along with it to
save reloading assets when you redeploy
the bike it's actually just moving there
extremely fast
which means the path between the
teleportation points will also catch on
fire
i know this baby hits 88 miles an hour
one of the coolest ways to surprise your
enemies
is to side jump off a skinny tree
did you notice that octoballon's stasis
launch momentum is linked to the weight
of the attached item
if it picks up a heavy object it will
require more hits to hit max launch
velocity
while a tiny object just needs about one
arrow i mean
it makes sense every horse has a max
water depth limit they can walk in
before they kick you off and have to
swim back onto land
but the giant horse's large stature
allows it to walk through deeper water
with no problem
now that is one chunky boy
in my last video i mentioned the golden
gauntlets technique where you can pick
up any object with ease and carry it
around without breaking a sweat
a side effect of this glitch though is
that it depends on which cardinal
direction that you're facing
because some directions cause the item
you try to pick up to turn completely
invisible
try this on an enemy that you can pick
up and they turn into a spooky ghost
that you can't even capture on camera
fatal frame won't work here
if you want some cool snapshots for your
profile picture or banner toast or
freeze some food you've never seen
before
then do an action like a charge attack
or a jump and pick up the new item
then switch weapons to what you prefer
now that is an epic looking link
recently players have been trying to
kill a gold lynel as fast as humanly
possible
using a new method to kill them in under
10 seconds by making the axis hitbox
permanently active on horseback
then swinging it manually using motion
controls this does extremely high damage
in a short time
i'm gonna call you out before you even
mention ancient arrows
no that is not a speed run as a wise man
once said
you get nothing you lose
good day sir one of hyrule's biggest
mysteries is how forest octorocks have
fish in them
these octorocks drown in water even if
they could kill the fish with the
rockshot how do they get to it if you
can't swim
we'll never know if you want to get real
comfy with ganon glide over to the
guardian stalkers on the ceiling for a
closer look perfect time for a selfie
while it's too complicated to explain in
the short form video the combination of
old and recently discovered glitches
including the new master sword stealing
glitch bow smuggling
and a specific octorok balloon weapon
duplication technique
creates a brand new arrow only smuggling
technique which link can then pull the
legendary master bomb
and there you go if you enjoy this
series and more check out our breath of
the wild expert series playlist
and for everything else gaming stay
tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
you